Минає 5 років від анексії Криму Росією.
А відео з протестами у Сімферополі кримчанка Олена без сліз і досі дивитись не може.
Тоді, наприкінці лютого, під Верховною Радою Криму
сталися сутички противників та прихильників референдуму за приєднання до Росії.
Втім ще більше емоцій у жінки викликають інші спогади.
Так деякі земляки Олени святкували результати псевдореферендуму,
який відбувся 16 березня 2014 року.
Це дуже дивувало, як це можна швидко так забути…і
це все це повністю був розподіл,
і я зрозуміла, що все, що більше з цими людьми, в цій державі, яка це робить, я жити не буду.
З сумом про мітинги в центрі Сімферополя згадує і родина кримських татар Кудусових.
Події розгортались швидко. Один день на ухвалення рішення про виїзд, дві години на пакування валіз…
Вечірній поїзд, він же один раз в добу йде. Чемодани накидали і виїхали.
Тепер замість краєвидів на Лівадійський палац,
родина Курдусових щоранку за кавою милується київськими багатоповерхівками.
Це вже п’яте житло, яке за ці роки довелося змінити
Лише нещодавно вони почали нарешті обживати орендовану квартиру -
перевозити деякі речі з Криму, купувати меблі.
Вони увійшли під стіл
Коли Росія анексувала Крим, Олені було 22.
До того моменту дівчина відчувала легкість життя, їй здавалося, що для неї відкритий увесь світ.
На курортному півострові, де і сонце, і гори, і море почуватися так було легко.
Олена місяцями могла відпочивати на піщаних пляжах не лише Криму, але й інших країн.
Вчила туристів кататись на кайті та серфінгу.
Про своє українське коріння задумалась лише тоді,
коли раптово для неї на півострові замайоріли російські прапори.
Мені як цивільній людині було це дивно.
Ти живеш, ти громадянин України, і просто поміняти паспорт
і стати громадянином країни-окупанта - для мене це було дивно.
Від окупаційної політики Росії влітку 2014-го Олена втекла до Івано-Франківська.
Думала, погостювати у друзів місяць-другий і повернутись.
Втім переслідування кримських татар та проукраїнських активістів
окупаційною владою змусило її змінити думку.
Коли ж стартувала реформи патрульної поліції в Івано-Франківську,
Олена зрозуміла - це її шанс по-своєму долучитись до змін в Україні.
А ще - вивчити українську мову.
Три місяці навчання.
У мене був блокнот, я записувала слова, які мені були незрозумілі, відповідно, губилась,
дуже довго думала, чи я зможу перейти переключитись,
бо все життя говорила виключно російською мовою.
Але мені настільки хотілось щось змінювати і служити,
і варіант був - нарешті вивчити українську мову.
Вже третій рік Олена патрулює вулиці галицького міста.
Сімейні сварки, дрібне хуліганство, вуличні крадіжки - це ті виклики, на які щодня реагує патрульна.
За цей час жодного разу зброю не використовувала.
Тихе і мирне життя міста її цілком влаштовує.
Та попри це, Олена мріє, що настане час, коли українська влада
реформуватиме правоохоронні органи і в Криму.
Це звісно моя мрія, щоб я могла патрулювати і служити у своєму рідному місті.
Бо ти там знаєш все: кожну вулицю, людей ти знаєш.
Це реальна мрія, щоб був український Севастополь
і щоб я туди приїхала з напарниками, і щоб все їм показала, і там просто несла службу.
Тим часом адаптація родини Кудусових із 4-ма дІтьми у Києві давалася непросто.
Ерфан був власником квіткового та блошиного ринків у Ялті,
колекціонував кримосьтатарські твори мистецтва.
Тож спершу вирішив і у Києві зайнятись звичною йому справою -
спробував відкрити магазин і арт-галерею.
Утім, кримський успіх повторити поки не вдалося.
Нині частина мистецької колекції зберігається вдома.
А інша - в підвалах Театру київської оперети,
де Ерфан два роки поспіль за символічну плату орендує приміщення.
Галерея не працює через ремонт театру. Знайти ж нове приміщення для галереї,
яка приносила доволі скудний прибуток, в туристичному центрі міста - не вдається.
Мені допомагають небагато, плюс я громадською активністю займаюсь,
активісти допомагають, друзі, родичі, щось здаємо кримське.
Але це все так.. ось був бізнес, який щось інколи приносив. Рідко, рідко.
Нині Кудусови отримують по тисячі гривень державної допомоги на кожну дитину.
Та всі гроші йдуть на комунальні послуги.
Ерфан пішов працювати в одну з політичних партій,
яка підтримує надання кримськотатарської автономії.
Це, на його думку, пришвидшило б деокупацію півострова.
Я взагалі не був громадським активістом, а тепер вимушений ним стати,
тому що наші проблеми, на жаль, ніхто не вирішує.
Нам доведеться їх самим вирішувати.
Олена знайшла ще одне покликання - допомагає притулку для безпритульних собак.
Нова робота, життя далеко від дому і батьків за ці 5 років її сильно змінили.
Стала більше дбати про інших і перейматися чужим горем.
Бо життя нас сильно поміняло, всіх переселенців, з ким би ви не поговорили,
вони знають, що все залежить від нас і не залежить ні від кого іншого.
І ти маєш сам для себе і сам змінювати себе, і таким чином змінювати країну.
Щотижня найменша донька Кудусових ходить в гурток на національні танці.
Для родини важливо, аби діти не забували кримськотатарське коріння та культуру.
Поки що як вимушені переселенці свою батьківщину ті бачать раз на рік, на літні канікули.